for a lawyer show it sounds like the
behind the scenes were absolutely insane
on She-Hulk dance parties pajama days
here's hoping the CGI Department wasn't
so swamped they could join in the fun
ready for a day in the life of a Hulk
number one improv is not everybody's
strong suit Tatiana maslani and Mark
Ruffalo loved improvising together
actually a ton of their little things
managed to make it into the show too we
found like weird you know little
digressions off of the script Ginger
gonzago is the most amazing improviser I
think I had a couple injuries to my ego
when I improvised something once and it
wasn't funny it's amazing that we move
through life improvising day in and day
out but once in front of the camera it's
suddenly considered a talent that some
people don't have number two She-Hulk is
customizable guys since the character is
all CGI so are all the outfits the
She-Hulk has 25 outfits which is a crazy
amount of different outfits most CG
characters get one outfit two if they're
lucky three if it's their birthday suit
she has to be in court she has to be
casual she has to be kind of working out
the outfit that stands out as an
impressive accomplishment though is her
sequin gala dress I think there are over
a million sequins that sparkle and
here's the dress before it got cgiified
worn by the stunning Malia Araya number
three all the heroes get to run around
with cool capes and Mark ruffalo's in
his jammies Ruffalo has always felt
insecure about his mocap suit often
being the only one on set to have to
wear the thing while all his co-stars
got cool costumes although there's not
much to be missed there all the costumed
actors wish they were in ruffalo's
position because those things are
uncomfy but anyway way Mark and Tatiana
bonded over the mocap suit wearing the
gray mo-cap suits with the camera in the
face made them feel other Hulk has
always felt like an outsider so it's
fitting and they really use that to bond
Mark's been alone for so long 10 years
eight movies eight movies in your
pajamas we can do that in one weekend
number four hitting below the belt is
not a super move Jamila Jamil was
kicking butt while suspended from wires
one shot that didn't make the cut was of
a very obviously painful crotch kick she
begged to have it left in the show but
alas it was cut the heroes generally
have a moral code and aren't usually the
ones to kick below the belt so it makes
sense too bad though that reaction is
priceless actually let's just play it
back once number five accidents happen
woof someone did fart in a scene and I'm
not allowed to say who that was any
hints but I feel like maybe she'll tell
you herself we're getting guessing it's
Tatiana but who do you think it was
number six turning green takes a little
more than anger okay one thing we don't
get is why they didn't cast Malia Araya
in the role of She-Hulk to begin with
and have a similar looking actor play
human Jennifer Walters because I'm 5'4
and she's six seven Malia is six foot
five portraying a six foot seven
character it's close enough the CGI
animators are all exhausted as is this
must have just been overwhelming given
She-Hulk is entirely CGI well maybe
there's a good reason for the casting
because Tatiana kept throwing off Ginger
who kept seeing the comic book character
come to life I kept bugging her I'd be
like I see the comic book again that's
some extremely good casting perhaps
Tatiana in a moment of fourth wall
breaking just crawled out of the page
when nobody was looking so the CGI work
was so intense on this show that they
had to create a new position there's a
CG lead which has never been done on a
Marvel television show before number
seven She-Hulk is being dubbed the the
party set so Tatiana and I started a
dance party there was a strange thing
that kept happening during some of the
scenes where we would end up dancing
with Benedict Wong Tatiana maslani and
her stunt double I feel like dancing was
a good Inn for me into She-Hulk Benedict
Wong would DJ for us in his character
outfit Wong actually had his DJ Gear
with him on his last day so when they
say dance parties you know they mean
real dance parties one day a
thunderstorm shut down production which
resulted in one Wicked dance party on
set we just kind of kept going in a
circle trying to grab different crew
members to join our dance party we would
find excuses for dancing to happen
either off-camera or on camera even if
it made zero sense number eight the
superpower of production Malia was
fitted with a muscle suit before trying
on every single costume that would need
to be cgi'd later on she also had to be
painted up in the green makeup while
being considered the most shy by her
co-stars they found out many fun facts
about her oh so slowly humble yeah multi
challenge yeah you can do a bunch of art
yeah she wraps number nine we are not
talking about a nicely cut lawn no when
you need something to look at while
you're acting opposite a giant CGI
She-Hulk look at a cardboard cutout a
stick on my head that had this kind of
like vacant green face just imagine how
hard it must be when you can't look at
your acting partner's Expressions just
the boring cardboard cutout face
number 10 can you guess who's the
snackiest I'm always taking leftovers
from Jessica and trying to eat them in
the scene maybe Nikki is the next Iron
Man Robert Downey Jr was notorious for
doing the same thing Ginger is a snacker
and would bring some weird weird snacks
to set like chicken chips and every time
you look at her expect to see a honey
stick in her mouth you always have like
a honey stick in your mouth number 11.
we didn't think Marvel let anybody do
anything by themselves Jamila Jamil
plays our new favorite villain Titania
and a first from what we've heard is she
gets to do her own makeup on set like
seriously that's unheard of she's got a
sense of humor about it too saying she
was lucky she got to do her own makeup
because it saves time and meant she got
to sleep more
I do it by myself Ginger Gonzaga got to
work closely with the costume designers
and makeup designers on her look too
once she had anything that felt a little
too loud or defiant but Chic and fun
then I felt like I was Nikki Ginger had
a story behind every single look she
wore too I knew there was like a lot of
curation but I didn't know it was like
see if you can figure out each one on
the re-watch we tried to base all of our
looks on some women in history sometimes
just a disco ball number 12 comedy needs
grounding Jamila Jamil was the only
choice for me sometimes when you write a
character that's absolutely ridiculously
out there you need an actor who can
tackle them with Grace they need the
comedic chops but also the ability to
ground ridiculous ideas in something
real I knew that she could bring reality
to a character that is so out there
number 13 She-Hulk is breaking down
walls all the walls not just the fourth
one it all has this tongue-in-cheek
self-referential thing going on no
Marvel isn't taking a huge creative risk
here first off Deadpool second off it's
in the comics from the comics she broke
the fourth wall and was super meta
number 14. next time pick somebody your
own size in the opening of the finale
Ali She-Hulk was not played by Malia
Araya and was actually played by a man
Devin Lewis only for the dream sequence
though number 15. there's nobody named
Jen in this show why are they chanting
it there was a time where everyone
needed to chant She-Hulk and we were all
very tired they started chanting Jen
Hulk instead in a very unsettling and
weird tone thanks to the sleep
deprivation and it was just very very
creepy the things you remember sometimes
She-Hulk lots of dancing pajamas awesome
food are we absolutely sure it was a
film set and not a slumber party what we
wouldn't give to be invited to that of
all the Marvel sets in the world which
one would you have loved to hang out on
let us know in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things